well a plumbing nightmare that's how a
woman describes the job she was promised
when she tried to replace her plumbing
system and the work stretched from a few
weeks to almost a year today Mary Lou
Thomas is speaking out in hopes others
don't fall into the similar problem
everything was Jack hammered I had piles
of dirt like three feet high all through
my house it's been headaches and lengthy
builds for 88 year old Mary Lou Thomas
after she was told her plumbing system
needed to be upgraded earlier this year
she says Drew's Plumbing was her go-to
service for years until this project
horrendous it started in March
the contract said two to three weeks I
paid the money and here I am nine months
later she says the work dragged and
became very confusing today she's left
with clear patches all across her
Winchester neighborhood home with bare
bathrooms and hallways when she reached
out to a different contractor to finish
the job the costs kept growing this
contractor should not be in business
anymore Paul Rosario with the Nevada
state contractors board says homeowners
need to reach out to their insurance or
get at least three bids before taking
any action on home repairs Rosario also
tells us the contractor did not have a
business license at the time of the work
charges against System 12 charges
against them of which 11 or 10 of the
charges were confirmed by the
administrative law judge and the
administrative law judge also revoked
his license for now Thomas's bedroom and
her son's room are taped off with
asbestos signs forcing both to live in
their garage den with their dog Chloe
the contractor Community is now working
together to step in and help through the
residential Recovery Fund it's been a
tremendous strain because it seems like
everything that could go wrong went
wrong